growing pressure on President Biden to
crack down on Mexican cartels after four
Americans are kidnapped with two of them
being murdered just across our Southern
border Texas Congressman Dan Crenshaw is
pushing for Action sharing his thoughts
and message for Mexico's president watch
this
spices
all right Congressman Dan Crenshaw
Wright joins us right now Congressman uh
great to see you thought a guy in Texas
with your military background would want
to take action here do you believe the
Mexican Government understands that we
need to take action here
well according to the Mexican president
he apparently doesn't he can't possibly
understand why we think that it's a bad
thing that over 70 000 Americans a year
being killed by fentanyl uh poisoning
and that poisoning is coming from two
main cartels the Cena Lo cartel and the
Jalisco cartel he doesn't seem to
understand it he called what I said
propaganda he said it's for electoral
purposes he has no idea what he's
talking about it's actually infuriating
and it should be infuriating to Mexicans
too because you know there's only one
other group of people that's terrorized
more by the Mexican cartels than
Americans and that's the Mexican people
they're sick of this they're sick of
their corrupt politicians taking money
from the cartels they want safety they
want prosperity and look and Americans
want that for the Mexico the country of
Mexico I mean if you could choose one
other country besides the United States
that you would make 10 times better than
it is right now you would choose Mexico
it's a very important Ally this
President needs to get out of the way
and work with us we just want to help
them one of the things the White House
said the other day uh Congressman was
that it was laughable she said that
fentanyl is at historically low levels
right now which we know the seizures are
way through the roof also she commented
uh kjp did on a suggestion you've had to
designate cartels as terrorist outfits
watch this
designating these cartels as ftos would
not grant us any additional authorities
that we don't really have at this time
so the United States has powerful
sanctions authorities specifically
designated to combat narcotics
trafficking organizations and the
individuals and entities that enable
them so we have not been afraid to use
them so your suggestion won't work she
says
well no I actually want to clarify
something so I I have never said we
should designate them as terrorists
there's a really good reason for that if
you designate them as terrorists you
just created millions of more legal
Asylum Seekers south of our border you
actually you actually make our
immigration crisis far far worse so this
is the one thing I agree with Iran now
she's totally wrong that the fentanyl
crisis is in an all-time low an all-time
low since when like last week like and
you know by how much I mean this is
ridiculous we're losing tens of
thousands of people we're we're
confiscating hundreds and hundreds of
pounds which can kill the entire
population in the United States 10 times
over just basically on a monthly basis
so you know she's absolutely wrong about
that what we need to do is is look
authorize military force now now that
means a couple things it doesn't mean
tanks rolling into Mexico the next day
what it means is we can use our
intelligence collections capabilities it
means we can work by with and through
the Mexican military in order to Target
them we can put our assets to bear on
this problem we I want to do it with the
government of Mexico and this is what I
would tell amlo the president of Mexico
we need to increase penalties against
them so all of the authorities that come
with the terrorist designation I have a
bill that gives you all of those
authorities uh you know goes after their
finances sanctions Mexican officials
that Aid and abet them without
designated them terrorists now look are
they obviously terrorists of course they
act like terrorists but if you designate
them that way you will make our
immigration crisis much worse and so I I
that's my message to a bunch of senators
too who are pushing legislation to that
end I know it makes it good it makes a
good headline but it's a really really
bad idea when it comes to our
immigration crisis yesterday active
service members and Veterans were in
Washington for the house Foreign Affairs
hearing one of many hearings we expect
to see and it was very emotional they
were talking about the withdrawal of
Afghanistan and former Marine Sergeant
Tyler Vargas Andrews I'm not sure if you
saw his testimony but it was he had to
take many moments just to pause because
he was getting emotional and crying he
lost 13 Americans there and he said they
were up in the tower and his uh his team
leader was ready he's a sniper he was
ready to take out the suicide bomber and
they didn't get the A-Okay from the
military or from the administration so
they didn't do it and they think that
was the guy who was responsible for
killing 13 Americans listen to some of
that testimony and we'll get your
reaction on the other side
Flash in a massive wave of pressure
I'm throwing 12 feet onto the ground but
instantly knew what had happened I
opened my eyes to Marines dead or
unconscious lying around me
the withdrawal was a catastrophe in my
opinion
Dan he lost an arm he lost a leg 100 to
150 ball bearings were in his body he
said his right arm was shredded his
lower abdomen was soaked in Blood and
ripped open awful to hear that and many
of the parents of these Americans say
this could have all been prevented what
do you say
that they're absolutely right and that's
just a heartbreaking testimony yeah you
know and what's heartbreaking too I
think in the American people have
largely forgotten this and largely
forgotten who's responsible which is one
person it's president invited uh those
13 families haven't forgotten uh that
that brave Marine was just testifying he
certainly hasn't forgotten and and I
want them to know that republicans in
Congress haven't forgotten either uh
that's why we're doing these hearings
that's why we're going to hold President
Biden accountable this was a disaster on
ethics scale that the decision making
was was so poorly thought out I mean but
let's just list a few things pulling out
of of Kabul Airport instead of Bagram so
they decided to evacuate biograph
because President Biden wanted one thing
he wanted zero troops that was his
entire policy right zero troops now his
military told him this was a terrible
idea he didn't listen to them all right
then he put State Department in charge
instead of the military so they didn't
have these clear Rules of Engagement and
that's why this Marine didn't know what
he was supposed to do because they were
wouldn't give him that clear Direction
it was horrible and it was it was just
completely unacceptable President Biden
is to blame
and you're sharing the screen with some
of the most horrific military images you
could possibly have uh that day and how
many people left behind and private
organizations had to go save them not
our military which is horrific uh Dan
thanks so much thank you great to be
with you all right I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis